So, let's talk a little bit about our procedure here. The first thing
we want to do is build a list of all carrier values. We could do
that by hand, might actually be a little easier to do it that way
just by looking at the HTML. We then need to build a list of
airport values. Now there are a lot of values here. So what we
probably want to do is actually write a
little script that will actually pull those
out. Okay. So all pages are going to have exactly the same list for
both of these. So we can just use the browser to download an example
page and pull those values out. Next, what we need to do
is make HTTP requests to download all the data. I'll talk about
why we want to download it all in just a minute. Then what
we want to to is parse the data files. The reason why we
want to do it this way, is because, in building our parser we
want to make sure we're working with data that isn't going to change.
And after the fact, once we do a little bit of data
cleaning, we may discover that the reason why we've got some dirty
data is actually because we have a bug in our parser. Much easier
to figure out where that bug is if we've still got the original data
we were using to parse. I should also point out that it really
doesn't make sense to download the data over and over again as we're figuring
out how to parse it. Something else you might want to keep in
mind is that for years prior to the current year the data isn't going
to change, so there's no reason to retrieve it more than once. So this
is actually a bit of a best practice. When you've got a situation like
the one we have here and when you've got a scraping
task it's often going to look something like this. You really want
to grab all the data you need first and then do your
scraping into separate process. So what we have for this particular problem
is essentially three different steps. We first have to build all the
values we're going to use to make HTTP request. We then need
to make all the HTTP request, and download the data we need.
And then finally, we're going to parse the data we want out
of those data files, shaping it into the particular pieces
of data, the particular items that we want to use.